here's a legal Pro tip if your video
tapes have been subpoenaed by the
Department of Justice don't immediately
engage in a criminal conspiracy to
destroy those tapes it's not the crime
it's the cover-up except here it's
definitely the crime but also it's
definitely the cover-up as well yes as
the world was waiting for Donald Trump
to be indicted in Washington DC in
Fulton County Georgia a special
prosecutor Jack Smith had a surprise up
his sleeve namely three additional
criminal charges against Trump in the
case alleging mishandling of classified
documents in Florida a grand jury has
now indicted Trump and two of his
employees for pressuring a Mar-A-Lago
employee to delete security footage that
had been subpoenaed by the government
the superseding indictment explains how
the two Trump employees walty NADA and
newly charged Carlos De Oliveira
attempted to delete security footage
because quote the boss wanted a server
deleted the new indictment also charges
Trump with willful retention of National
Defense information for the time up in
New Jersey when he showed a classified
document to random civilians see this
President I could have did last year no
I can't you know but this is
so let's dig into the new indictment the
superseding indictment is a formal
criminal complaint brought by a grand
jury to replace the original indictment
this usually happens when there is new
evidence that warrants an additional
charge and there's no such thing as an
amended indictment to add charges
prosecutors must grow through the same
process as the original indictment which
means a grand jury must weigh the new
evidence and once the grand jury Returns
the superseding indictment it replaces
the original indictment and that's what
happened here the superseding indictment
adds more facts to the original
allegations starting with a description
of Mr de Oliveira and then going into a
new section entitled the attempt to
delete security camera footage and as
always these are unproven allegations
from the doj they have not been proven
in court but also again given the volume
of verbatim quotes it definitely seems
like the doj is acting like they have
the goods and according to the new
indictment on June 3rd when FBI agents
were at Mar-A-Lago to collect boxes they
observed surveillance cameras near the
storage room on June 22nd the government
emailed to draft subpoena to Trump's
lawyer the subpoenas sought footage from
the ground floor where the boxes were
being stored the next day after being
tipped off about the request from the
government on June 23rd Trump called
Dale Oliveira and they spoke for 24
minutes on June 24th the Department of
Justice sent a final subpoena to Trump
attorney number one which sought quote
any and all surveillance records videos
images photographs and or CCTV from
internal cameras at 1 25 PM the lawyer
called Trump about the government
subpoena and then what about
surveillance cameras
what's wrong with that what's wrong with
like are those yours why can't you clean
why can't you clear them I don't
understand that the phone call from the
lawyer to Trump establishes that Trump
was on notice that he could not destroy
or delete any material that was
responsive to The subpoena at 3 34 PM an
unnamed Trump employee referred to as
Trump employee number three texted NADA
and told him that Trump wanted to speak
with him although NADA was scheduled to
travel with Trump to Illinois the next
day now to change his schedule and
travel to Mar-A-Lago instead and the
indictment says that now to quote
provided inconsistent explanations to
his co-workers for his sudden travel to
Florida and of course use the shushing
Emoji which might as well be the
official mascot of criminal conspiracies
now on the night of June 24th de
Oliveira and now detected an unnamed
Trump employee who was director of
Information Technology at mar-a Lago and
as you can see from this exchange the
three Bros chat about their plans for
the weekend requesting that the IT
director yusel Tavares helped them out
on Saturday and from the indictment it
reads at 502 PM now to send text
messages to Trump employee for asking
hey bro you around this weekend at 505
PM now to text to Dale Oliveira asking
hey brother you working today Dale
Oliveira responded Yes I just left now
to then call Dale Lavera and they spoke
for approximately two minutes at 509 PM
Trump employee number four texts today
response now to quote I am local
entertaining some family that came to
visit what's up NADA responded to Trump
employee number four okay cool no biggie
just wanted to see if you were around
enjoy bro at 6 56 PM de Oliveira texted
Trump employee for hey buddy how are you
Walter called me early said it was
trying to get in touch with you I guess
he's coming down tomorrow I guess needs
you for something Trump employee 4
responded he reached out but he didn't
say what he wanted I told him I was
local but entertaining some family that
came from NYC this weekend he told me to
no worries at 6 58 PM Trump employee 4
texted NADA bro if you need me I can get
away for a few just let me know now to
responds sounds good thank you on
Saturday June 25th day Oliveira told a
valet at Mar-A-Lago that NADA was flying
from Bedminster to Florida but he needed
the trip to be secret and despite the
very cutesy nature of this project Dale
Oliveira couldn't help but tell the
valet that nauda had tapped Dale Vera to
do an important job talk with the I.T
director about how long security footage
was stored and shortly after now it
arrived on June 25th he and Dale Lavera
went to Mar-A-Lago they entered the
security booth where the security videos
are shown on monitors the two defendants
took flashlights into the tunnel where
the storage room was located pointing
out the security cameras the cameras
which presumably recorded their little
Excursion pointing out the cameras which
was probably really handy for the
prosecutors when they presented this
evidence to the grand jury now on Monday
June 27 2022 de Lavere summoned the I.T
director to a basement tunnel and then
walked with him to an audio Closet near
the golden white Ballroom which we've
talked about and made fun of at length
here now Dale oliveir told the employee
that quote the conversation should
remain between the two of them and that
obviously clearly worked here but he
asked him employee how long the servers
retained these surveillance footage when
the IT director said 45 days Dale avere
told him to delete the video quote de
Lavera told the employee the boss wanted
the server deleted the IT director quote
responded that he would not know how to
do that and that he quote did not
believe he would have the rights to do
that the IT director said he would need
to hear from one of Trump's business
Security Guys from the Trump
organization to fulfill that request
they Oliver repeated that quote the boss
wanted the server deleted deliver then
said what are we going to do now this is
pretty obvious but given that the IT
director Tavares is not named in the
indictment and is the only other witness
besides Ayla Vera to some of these
conversations it probably means that
he's cooperating with the doj and is
providing testimony and a bit of advice
if someone ever tells you to delete
files at work regardless of whether
there is an actual known federal
investigation at place your answer
should be can you please put that
request in writing no one will ever know
no one will ever know
you sent me to shred the records of off
book hush money and illegal intimidation
so after this exchange with the I.T
director Dale Vera did know what to do
he called up Walt NADA and after text in
a chat now to text to De Oliveira on my
way to you Dale Oliveira traips through
the bushes to meet up clandestine Lee he
thought with now to add an adjacent
property de Oliveira then hiked back
through the bushes at Mar-A-Lago and
went to the it office before returning
to the other property to meet NADA again
through the bushes and then later that
day Trump called de Oliveira and they
had a three-minute phone conversation in
July of 2022 the government got some of
the footage that was in response to the
subpoena and on August 8th this search
warrant was served and then the
indictment goes on to explain what might
be witness tampering paragraph 91 just
over two weeks after the FBI discovered
classified documents in the storage room
in Trump's office on August 26 2022 now
to call Trump employee 5 and said words
the effect of someone just wants to make
sure Carlos is good in response Trump
employee 5 told now to the day Oliveira
was loyal and Oliveira would not do
anything to affect his relationship with
Trump I expect
loyalty that same day at NATO's request
Trump employee 5 confirmed in a signal
group chat with nouda and the PAC
representative that Dale Lavera was
loyal that same day Trump called Dale
Lavera and told Dale Lavera that Trump
would get Dale Lavera an attorney now
presumably employee 5 testified
independently about this that Pac
representative appears to be Susie Wiles
who has had multiple meetings with doj
and I imagine a criminal conspiracy
perpetrated via a group signal chat
probably violates the Independence that
Pax are supposed to have with political
candidates and I kind of wonder where
those Super PAC funds have been going
and for what purpose I don't know it
looks bad and then there's also the pool
flood incident that happened when the
investigation was mostly stalled because
of Judge Cannon it appears that Dale
Oliveira was the one who drained the
pool at Mar-A-Lago which subsequently
flooded the room where the surveillance
logs were stored last October and that
would suggest that the flooding was
potentially an intentional part of
Trump's cover-up now uh we can't be sure
but legal eagle has acquired exclusive
video footage of those employees
attempting to bypass the server security
measures to erase inculpatory evidence
now as you can probably already tell
Trump and his valleys are going to need
a good lawyer now if you need a great
lawyer my firm the eagle team can help
if you've been in a car crash suffered a
data breach or have social security
disability issues we can represent you
or help find you the right attorney just
click on the link in the description for
a free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team and the link is down
below now as for Trump's role in the new
charges he was indicted on three more
counts the superseding indictment adds a
new account 32 charging Trump with one
additional count of unlawful retention
of National Defense information there's
been a lot of speculation about whether
Trump would be charged for the unlawful
retention of ndi for the document he
apparently showed people at Bedminster
to review the original indictment
contained a transcript of a conversation
Trump had with his staff and two authors
who were working on a book for Mark
Meadows in that conversation Trump seems
to show a document describe it as
classified and say that he could have
Declassified it but it was still a
secret and Jack Smith's team added an
additional sentence to the superseding
indictment to indicate that he has now
been indicted for willful retention of
that document and it appears that the
doj now has a document in question which
allegedly lays out a plan to invade a
foreign country Trump took Flack for
allegedly being interested in invading a
foreign country to deflect from his own
domestic issues while he was president
but Trump blamed general milley for that
particular plan which is why in the
audio clip he says that the top secret
document which he apparently has in his
hand totally wins his case because it
was prepared by Millie this totally wins
my case you know and I guess you really
need to pick your battles here but in
any event if you haven't heard the real
audio of that conversation uh check out
the short that I did on it where you can
hear what was left out of the
indictments transcript in the leaked
audio Trump basically admitted that he
did not declassify the document and
because these actions took place in
Bedminster New Jersey it's possible that
there might be another indictment there
but it's still unclear to me why the doj
never issued a subpoena or search
warrant for Bedminster at least not one
that's public now Trump Dale Oliveira
and now that we're charged with
conspiracy to obstruct Justice and
violation of 18 USC 1512k the three men
are alleged to have conspired to
withhold a record document or other
object from an official proceeding in
violation of 1512 and not surprisingly
the three defendants are accused of
attempting to violate 1512c which
forbids a corruptly altering destroying
mutilating or concealing a record with
the intent to impair the object's
Integrity or availability for use in an
official proceeding and they're also
charged with trying to keep the security
footage from being provided to a Federal
grand jury and it's certainly worth
paying attention to section 1512 because
if and when Trump is indicted for crimes
connected to January 6th it's extremely
possible that he might be charged with a
15-12 violation in those proceedings as
well now additionally de Lavera is
charged with making false statements to
Federal authorities in violation of 18
USC 1001 the indictment says that during
a voluntary interview with the FBI in
January of 2022 de Lavera made
representations that were materially
false fictitious or fraudulent when Dale
Avera lied about being involved in any
group that helped move boxes de Oliveira
told the FBI that he had neither seen
nor heard anything about boxes being
moved or stored at Mar-A-Lago and the
original Diamond said that NADA worked
with a Mar-A-Lago employee to move
approximately 30 boxes from Trump's
residence to the storage room on June
2nd 2022 and the superseding indictment
identifies de Oliveira as that employee
and the new indictment also says that
day Oliveira helps now to load boxes and
other items onto an airplane that flew
Trump North for the summer now it's
probably fair to say that if Dale Lavera
had cooperated with the government he
might not be facing these charges today
but hey he's loyal to Trump and we all
know that Trump rewards those who are
loyal to him
right
now Trump's additional charges have been
covered extensively by more than 231
news sources 33 of the reporting comes
from the left and 16 is coming from the
right and if you compare the headlines
you start to see something interesting
in the framing on the left you have
Outlets teasing the real goal of the
charges and on the right you have others
highlighting Trump's statements about
the special counsel being deranged and
you can draw from those examples your
own conclusions and this is all possible
thanks to today's sponsor ground news a
website map developed by a former NASA
engineer on a mission to give readers an
easy data-driven objective way to read
the news every story comes with a quick
visual breakdown of the political bias
factuality and ownership of these
sources reporting all backed by ratings
from three Independent News monitoring
organizations and I especially like the
blind spot feed which highlights stories
that are disproportionately covered by
one side of the political spectrum
because it's important to know what
circulating online in Echo Chambers
instead of being in the dark about
misleading media narratives on both
sides and maybe we can even challenge
some of our own assumptions and with
around news Vantage plan you get all of
their features plus access to the my
news bias feature which is basically a
dashboard for your news diet you can see
how your reading habits change what are
your top sources and whether you're
seeing diverse perspectives and if you
use my link you'll get 30 off of the
ground news Vantage subscription just
click on the link that's on screen right
now or down in the description you'll
get a fascinating and more objective
look at the news and help support
independent and transparent reporting so
to get 30 off just click on the link
below and after that click on this link
over here for more legal eagle or I'll
see you in court